hey 42 here if you happen to be
traveling through the u.s state of
kentucky in the early 1930s
you couldn't have asked for a finer
place to rest your head for the night
than the hatcher hotel in pikeville
built by
local businessman james hatcher the
hotel was proudly
fireproof and had a small museum in the
reception area
two things i always looked for when
booking a place to stay
hatch's hotel was a bit of a strange one
he had his favorite
sayings and quotes written all over the
walls of the lobby
and the museum contained an odd mix of
artifacts
including an iron lung which was
high-tech medical equipment at the time
easily the most bizarre object on
display though
was hatcher's coffin which he had built
years before his death
ignoring for a moment the weirdness of
introducing
hotel guests to the box you're going to
be buried in
there was something unique about this
coffin
it was built to escape with latches
on the inside which necessitated a
specially made
tool for sealing the box before placing
it in its tomb
hatcher's coffin was designed to prevent
him from being buried alive and who
could blame him
local historians tell the story of
hatcher's wife octavia
who he'd married in 1889 after the
couple's only son
died shortly after birth in january 1891
octavia entered a deep depression from
which she would never recover
her condition gradually worsened until
she fell into a coma and died being
pronounced dead
on the 2nd of may 1891
in those days embalming wasn't a common
practice yet
and no refrigeration meant there was no
morgues to keep
bodies cool so people were generally put
in the ground as soon as possible after
death
to avoid the rather unpleasant reality
of putrefaction it was an unusually hot
summer in pikeville last year so octavia
hatcher was buried with
even more haste than was usual then
a few days passed by and other townsfolk
also began to show signs of
severe sleepiness lapsing into comas
just like octavia today there are
numerous theories for what caused this
illness
ranging from mosquitoes to tetsy flies
to toxic gases escaping from a nearby
mine
but at the time hatcher was simply
worried by the similarities between the
sleeping sickness
and his wife's condition so just to be
on the safe side
he sought permission to dig up his
wife's body
and he was met with a harrowing scene
the inner lining of the coffin had been
torn
and octavia's fingers were bloodied from
scratching
at the lid her face was allegedly
twisted with fear
and there was no doubt she had died a
horrible and prolonged death
some fairly sizable question marks hang
over the story of octavia's premature
burial
not least because there's no documented
evidence to actually support it
but for many people it provides a neat
reason for why james hatcher
felt so compelled to build himself an
escapeable coffin
but many folk back then who didn't even
have an
undead wife to their name shared
hatcher's fear
being buried alive known as tephobia
and it was quite common in the 19th
century
given the standard of medical science at
the time it's not hard to see why
oh sorry i didn't see you there i love
cereal honestly i'd eat it for dinner if
i could
but everyone knows that cereal is full
of sugar
but that doesn't stop our cereal
cravings does it
so what if you could relive all the best
cereals from your
childhood but without the calories
well you can with magic spoon
magic spoon tastes exactly like the
cereal you know and
love however it's incredibly nutritious
to be precise it contains 14 grams of
protein
only four net grams of carbs and is only
140 calories per servings
and the best bit zero grams of sugar
zero magic spoon offers a variety of
flavors
but don't worry if you can't decide
because you can try all of magic spoons
best selling options in their variety
pack magic spoon is keto friendly
low carb and caters for a number of
intolerances
because it's also gluten grain and soy
free
i genuinely can't believe how something
so nutritious
can taste that darn amazing so
if you're ready to start enjoying cereal
again without the guilt
you can click the link below to grab a
variety pack
and try it out and be sure to use the
promo code
42 at checkout to get 5 off
any order or you can also head to
magicspoon.com
forward slash 42 and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100
happiness guarantee so if for any reason
you don't like it
they'll refund your money no questions
asked
so click the link below or head to
magicspoon.com
forward slash 42 to save five dollars
by using the code 42. we tend to think
of death as an instantaneous process
now you see me now you don't but it can
actually be quite drawn out
with different parts of the body
shutting down in different stages
your body can remain alive for example
even after your brain
is dead whilst there's also evidence to
suggest
that the brain keeps working after the
heart
has stopped that makes it difficult
enough to determine
exactly when someone has died but then
there's also some medical conditions
that make the doctor's job even harder
in january of 2018 a man in the astorias
region of spain
was pronounced dead by three different
doctors then just a few hours before his
autopsy
he was heard snoring in the morgue
doctors had already made marks on his
body
ready for the post-mortem dissection
once everyone had calmed down
from holy crap we almost cut open
a living human being sober scientific
reflections suggested
the man may have had catalepsy symptoms
of catalepsy include
rigid limbs total lack of responsiveness
and a slowing of bodily functions
vital signs like breathing and heart
rate
can be so reduced that they're virtually
impossible to detect
even by doctors in the 21st century
in 1915 ezzy dunbar a woman in south
carolina
suffering from catalepsy's cousin
epilepsy
was pronounced dead by a doctor after
suffering a severe
epileptic fit she was buried the next
day
but then dug back up a short while later
after her sister
who was late for the funeral begged to
be allowed to say
a final farewell to her body
but when they opened the coffin essie
sat
up smiling apparently unaware of
anything that had happened
but that's not the full story the priest
then suffered severe injuries
after falling into the grave with shock
and
essie was labeled a zombie but you can't
have everything in life can you
now imagine what things must have been
like before the invention of the
stethoscope in 1816
even without extreme epilepsy or
conditions like catalepsy
there are many illnesses that can render
signs of life
undetectable to the naked eye so it's
easy to see how
death may have been misdiagnosed in the
past
back then the most scientific ways of
determining whether someone was still
living or not
involved using feathers or mirrors to
check for signs of breath
tales of accidental burials go back as
far as the 14th century
upon opening the tomb of middle ages
philosopher
john dun scotus witnesses found his body
outside his coffin with his hands
badly damaged from trying to escape
another famous story dates back to the
1600s in
england when a woman named alice blunden
passed out after drinking a large draft
of poppy seed tea
of course a large volume of poppy seeds
contains enough morphine and
codeine to knock out a giraffe
no not really i just said that for
dramatic effect
but it probably would have left alice
heavily sedated
after applying the foolproof mirror test
to confirm that alice was indeed
a goner she was pronounced dead and
promptly buried
two days later though children playing
near the gravesite
which was apparently a normal thing to
do in the 17th century
heard noises and went to call our
schoolmaster after realising that alice
was still
clearly alive down there work began to
exhume her
but since it took almost a day to do so
she was teetering on death by the time
they reached her
seeing what a bad state she was in those
responsible obviously decided to save
themselves some time
and simply chucked her back in the
ground it was clearly a tough time to be
alive
or dead i guess on this occasion
at least a guard was left to make sure
alice didn't spring back to life again
not much good it did her though he
ditched his post
and alice was found dead the next
morning
after having tried to escape from her
coffin once more
stories like these as well as countless
urban legends and folk tales
fueled widespread to phobia peaking
during the cholera epidemics
of the 1800s in 1895 british magazine
spectator
declared that burning drowning even the
most hideous mutilation
under a railway train is as nothing
compared with burial alive
popular writers like edda allen poe
fueled fears with stories like
premature burial in which the narrator
who is terrified of being buried alive
does everything possible to avoid the
situation
but ends up waking up underground anyway
sorry i should have give you a spoiler
alert there
you might want to find a different 17th
century short story to read this evening
even the more cultured and educated of
society were bricking it
legendary musician frederick chopin
insisted
that his heart be cut out when he died
to make sure
he was truly dead george washington
wanted his body watched over
for three days before he was buried
whilst
danish writer hans christian anderson
and
swedish polymath alfred nobel both
asked for their arteries to be cut open
when they passed away
just to be sure anderson also used to
sleep with a sign that said
i am not dead to illustrate how common a
concern this was
look no further than death houses which
were built to allow a buffer between
death and burial one example
the apparent death house in the hague
the netherlands
can still be visited today established
in 1830 the building has a central room
that was used to house the recently dead
there they would be monitored by
attendants who would periodically check
for signs of breathing
the bodies were also surrounded by
strings connected to bells
in case the dead woke up and fancied
playing a tune
only if after a few days there were
still no signs of life
would the now ripe corpses be committed
to the ground for good
in germany at the turn of the 19th
century lichen houses
or waiting houses became popular to
store corpses
until they began decomposing and were
obviously dead
some were scented with piles of flowers
whilst
others allowed people to pay entry and
wonder amongst the decaying bodies
which now i think about it is quite an
improvement on some of the dates i've
been on in my life it didn't take long
for inventors and entrepreneurs to come
up with creative ways
to avoid accidental burial in 1752
frenchman antoine louis created one of
the more
unpleasant jobs in history when he
suggested
giving the dead tobacco enemas
to check if they were still alive the
technique which apparently has no
connection to the phrase
to blow smoke up someone's ass was
already being used to resuscitate
drown victims and remained a popular way
of testing for death
right into the 19th century one french
priest
suggested replacing the tobacco smoke
with a red hot poker
but unsurprisingly the idea never caught
on
not even amongst the dead people amply
illustrating why his country gave birth
to the word
sadist it was yet another frenchman who
invented
the pons mamalon or nipple pincher
a pair of giant tweezers that were used
to
well i'm pretty sure you can work that
one out for yourself
of course the french weren't the only
ones to come up with clever but
twisted ways of confirming mortality
across the channel in england some
bright spark
thought of writing the words i am dead
in silver nitrate on a pane of glass
before hanging the glass above the dead
body
in a coffin the writing would be
revealed when the gases from the
decomposing body
reacted with the silver nitrate
indicating to the undertaker
and anyone within 10 meters who had a
sense of smell
that the person was definitely dead
but these macabre contraptions did
little to allay people's fears
and by far the most desirable
post-bucket kicking
commodity were safety coffins
one common design element as in the
coffin displayed by james hatcher in his
hotel museum
was a latch on the inside of the coffin
to allow the occupant to
open it from within which obviously only
had practical use if the person was
buried in a tomb
and not under six feet of earth of
course this was the case for most people
who wanted safety coffins
as poorer people the type that gets
graves
not tombs wouldn't have been able to
afford safety coffins anyway another
popular design option was to include
some sort of window the first known
order for a safety coffin
was from duke ferdinand of brunswick who
died in 1792
his coffin had a window to allow
lighting plus a tube for fresh air
and a series of locks that could be
unlocked from the inside
to this day if you visit the graveyard
of town hill road
in new haven vermont you can find the
grave of timothy clark smith
a 19th century doctor who had a window
inserted in a horizontal gravestone
directly above where his head would have
been situated
when he was laid to rest he was also
buried with a breathing tube and a bell
and the tomb included a set of stairs
that could be used to climb out
i'm fairly sure he's dead now one coffin
designed by german adolph gutsmith
included a feeding tube the inventor
proved how effective it was by spending
a few hours underground
during which time he ate a meal of soup
bratwurst
marzipan sauerkraut spatula beer
and the dessert because everyone knows
that the most pressing concern when
you've just been buried alive
is to have a relaxing four course meal
by far the most popular device in safety
coffins
with some form of bell that allowed the
person to ring it
and notify those above ground that they
were indeed
still alive this has spawned a range of
misconceptions about phrases like
dead ringer graveyard shift and
saved by the bell all of which are
forced to have something to do with
safety coffins used in the victorian era
in fact none of these figures of speech
are connected with
accidental burial at all as far as we
know
nobody has been saved by a safety coffin
but don't worry
they're still available if you need
something to soothe your tephobia
in 1995 a patent was registered for a
safety coffin
that included an intercom system an
emergency alarm
a torch breathing apparatus and a heart
monitor
of course you could just be buried with
your phone instead
providing you can get signals six feet
under the fear of being buried alive is
a lot less common these days
partly because of more advanced medical
techniques and partly because of modern
methods for corpse preservation
arterial embalming introduced in the
late 19th century
involves replacing the blood in the
human body with embalming fluid
and since that fluid is usually a mix of
formaldehyde
methanol and ethanol there's little
chance of you being alive afterwards
anyway
that doesn't mean things still don't go
wrong though
in 2018 brazilian woman rosangela
almeida dos santos
was buried after dying from septic shock
following two
heart attacks eleven days later though
her family was alerted
after a passerby heard noises coming
from her concrete tomb
her family broke the tomb open and took
out the wooden coffin
but it was too late dos santos had died
she had clearly been trying to fight her
way out of her coffin
with damage to her hands and forehead as
well as blood around the inside of the
casket
even the nails used to keep the coffin
closed
had been loosened by her efforts so when
it comes time for you to
shuffle off this mortal coil make sure
you're put in the ground
by someone you trust and preferably
someone
who's not a beneficiary on your life
insurance policy
thanks for watching